you're constantly
meeting fans that have tattooed your
faces on their bodies
and i don't know how that i mean that's
got to be a strange feeling it it
yeah it's a little [ __ ] you wonder you
start to wonder about people
you know you start to wonder like is
that really the choice you want to make
that's that's
that's there for life choice yeah you
know i mean
it's a big deal you want to make sure
you're tattooing the right thing on your
body when you make a choice like that
right yeah well i know we have real ones
this is look at this uh these are real
tattoos
this is a fan's tattoo of charlie
looking like an ass there you go the
nice
rob tattoo yeah here's i think we have a
danny
yeah how do you feel about that danny oh
man that is
yeah cool that's on danny that's on
danny's
and then uh i think uh glenn yeah
there's a glenn tattoo yeah yeah
i mean that is it that is a commitment
that's going to be there for their
entire life
it's it is a big deal you want to make
sure that you're picking your favorite
character i mean i don't think it's that
strange to make a choice like that i
just think that
you've got to make sure you're picking
somebody you really feel strongly about
i also
i've never liked anyone that much really
i mean i
i personally i mean i have a i have a
tattoo of somebody who i've admired for
many many years on my body who's a
television character and a film star
oh really yeah can we see it is that
okay you guys want to see it yeah what's
your tattoo
it's cool
what's great is that's never going to go
out of style right exactly that's my
thought exact quickly down under
yeah three men and a baby three men and
a little lady
yeah yeah magnum p.i it's not that way i
mean i actually
you know i got i got i don't know
wow i'm just a big fan man when did you
i'm
a really big fan of yours and uh you
know not from sonny but from like must
love dogs
yeah yeah yeah that eddie show that
eddie shout out
to that funny show there's too much like
making out for people who know each
other yeah yeah
yeah yeah i tell you what though i i
think
and rob has rob has a tattoo and i think
if anybody should be embarrassed
because he made a bad choice it's
unfortunate embarrassed yeah you made a
bad
you know i mean i i got a tattoo of of
of a guy who's a cultural icon who i
grew up i
listen to his albums and um
he's had a rough patch recently but you
know like yeah i
wanted to get a tattoo of i don't know
if you can see it there can you see it
that's uh yeah david crosby
[Applause]
you see david crosby
no the mustache that's very clearly
david
no cosby no why would i put it
look oh
in a good way in a good way i made a
mistake
too then now that you have money you
altered it yourself
with a sharpie
you